I grew up in a farm
My childhood was wonderful
Because I grew up next to my father and worked in the field
One of the things I learned
The meaning of working throughout the day
So I wanted to become an entrepreneur
A few years ago I started with my partners from almost zero
Now we have more than 200 employees and more than 200 million downloads
As well as our partnership with Adidas. We have made great achievements.
I was 40 years old when I started running
The whole thing began with a challenge
My daughter, Alexis, registered in the jogging race 10 km
I decided to register myself in a 5 km race
To show my support for her and she will not run alone
Alexis does not think I can
She told me it was not so easy
I was advised to use the Runtastic application and accepted the challenge
I ran a full 5 km
Since I started running, I've been involved in all kinds of races
Currently I'm training for the second marathon
I learned from jogging that I could do a lot
By diagnosis, I have learning difficulties
School years were not easy
She then met the "Whitefield"
Which completely changed my life
The main idea of ​​the Remind application
Came from my desire to strengthen the abilities of teachers such as Miss "Whitefield"
And increase their effectiveness
In order to make a tremendous development in the educational system
So I was spending my time talking to
Hundreds of teachers throughout the country
While my brother was busy studying programming
Remind now employs more than 23 million teachers, students and parents
In more than 90% of US education areas
We were never able to reach these customers
If not Google Play
One of my students, Jason, was suffering
Of completing tasks on time
One day he came to tell me ...
Then I bet on
I will do all the homework and pass the test successfully
Provided you give us a party
I was constantly receiving messages from Miss "Limer"
And my classmates for my encouragement and support
She finally lost the bet
I gave the students an ice-cream party
Perhaps this was one of the best achievements
Which I saw achieve
There are more than 30 million users
Applicable at this time
We are larger than any university or school
It has existed for many years in India
Our inspiration and enthusiasm
Is to hear others talk about
The effectiveness of learning English using the application
And how much they benefit from it
This gives us greater strength to continue
And strive to make a greater impact
When she retired
I decided to do something useful
So I joined Hello English
I think many children around us want to
learn English
Joining Hello English has given me enough confidence
To go to my towns and educate the poor and the needy
welcome
how are you?
what's your name?
Bogar
Wonderful
My name is Sidhar
English is useful for higher education
And open up to you better areas of life
I began to establish Sesame about five years ago
I was working in computer vision
And gesture technology
And appeared on TV to display the game
Developed and controlled by head gestures
I received a call the next day
Someone told me that he was unable to move his hands or legs
He asked me to make him a smart phone that he could use
He came and looked at me to tell me
That he founded a new company
I told him that this would be a lot better
To help the world
I was convinced by my point of view
My company has provided a new perspective
About what technology can do
And their ability to change their lifestyle
Allows me to modify the Android operating system
Make more innovations than I imagined at first
There are things I do and I could not do before
I could not handle my smartphone
My life has changed completely
User success is not just a number
Success is the fruit of a full life with its various details and events
Those successful people joined us in supporting our success.